because she's British and you should
never have been taken away in the first
place this country is responsible for
its citizens just as other countries are
responsible for theirs
she is a bethnal green schoolgirl born
and raised in this country lived here
her entire life until lured to Syria 15
years old she is as British as I am and
this is where she belongs she could have
been successful in taking the lives of
many British people and if that had
happened then she should be investigated
and perhaps prosecuted for it just as
any other British citizen just as I
would be if I had done something like
that
doesn't change the fact that she's a
British person being a British person
throughout her life
this is where she belongs and this
country is responsible for her